Yeah,
I didn't like that.
All right, good evening everyone.
Welcome to the Finance Committee
committee meeting [music] for April
20th.
We're going to jump right in with new
resolution starting with temporary
resolution 4126. That's coming through
Finance.
We're going to discuss the Health
Department contract for 2027, Mr. Mayor.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Uh so, every
year um
the last
well, 20-plus years, I believe, uh we've
been contracting with Fairfield County
Board of Health for
Health Department um
services for the city of Lancaster.
Uh
this contract is the same as it has been
for many years. You'll see the scope of
services
and things outlined
in the contract have not changed. The
one thing that has [clears throat]
changed is a a 3% increase in the fee
that we are paying.
Um
you may or may not know, but our revised
code, we are required to have a health
department. It's uh
a lot better financially if we contract
with Fairfield County, and they've
provided it uh provided great services
over the years, and uh
uh recommending we move forward with the
contract.
All right.
Anyone have any questions on that piece?
I do.
Yes, ma'am.
>> Um is there a reason there was a 2%
increase last last year, and now there's
a three, or is it just
So, I believe it's just the the
financial situation the the the entire
country's facing with inflation. They
have uh assured us that through the
years, when they uh do uh put a a cost
increase in there, they'll keep it as
low as possible. Uh their 3% is fairly
minimal considering the scope of
services. Okay. Fair enough. Thank you.
Any other questions?
Seeing none, I have that as three
readings. Mr. Ailes will be my second.
Moving on, temporary resolution 4226
coming through Safety Committee, Mr.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chair. Um this resolution
here is seeking to appropriate $43,000
here um from the unencumbered balance
into our retirement line item. Uh this
is due to the new retirement of
Lieutenant Jim Baker uh from the
Lancaster Fire Department. So, uh it was
initially not planned for, so we got to
make this
uh legislation, we got to make this
appropriation now
uh just to make sure we meet that uh
contractual obligation. Uh I also want
to take the time to thank Lieutenant Jim
Baker for his years of service on LFD.
So, that being said, I have nothing more
to say, uh Mr. Chair, other than we're
uh going for three readings, and Mr. Aug
will be my second.
Perfect. Thank you. Any questions on
that?
Seeing none, we'll move on to temporary
resolution 4326, also through Safety
Committee, Mr. Bisjack.
>> Uh thank you, Mr. Chair. Uh once again,
this legislation now it it may look like
on the surface here that we're
appropriating an additional $200,000 for
this design. And I want to provide some
clarity to Council and the public at
large here um that this is actually not
an increase in $200,000 in expenditures.
Essentially, what happened was uh there
was a purchase order from 2025 that, due
to governmental accounting practices,
the city had to close. And since the
Fire Department didn't expend everything
from that purchase order, whatever money
was left over automatically reverted
into the
uh unencumbered balance for the 2046,
which is the 0.15 levy fire levy fund.
And since they need to open up a new
purchase order, once again, to comply
with governmental accounting practices
in 2026,
like I said, that money flows into that
unencumbered balance. We then have to
re-appropriate that money from the
unencumbered balance back into the new
purchase order for 2026. So, at the end
of the day, this is not new money, this
is not increased expenditures, this is
not an additional expense. Like I said,
the legislation may read that way, but
this is something we discussed at length
in the Safety Committee meeting, that
was made clear to the Safety Committee,
and has our support. And uh so, we're
going to go three readings on this
Uh once again, uh we're also going to
have uh Mr. Sully be my second on the
legislation. So. Okay.
Thank you for the explanation. Any
questions?
All right.
Temporary resolution 4426, that's coming
through Water Water Pollution, Mr.
Ailes. Yes, I think Denise is here to
discuss this.
Good evening. Well, our quiet time is
over, and we are ready to start into
construction. Um this resolution
authorizes the Service Safety Director
to advertise for bids for the South
Water Plant backflow valves project.
What this is is we're going to install
backflows um somewhere around Fort
Street. We're still working with the
county on a final location.
Um and those valves are going on the
main transmission line from the South
Water [clears throat] Plant. As it is
now, if there would be a break in that
line, we would be in danger of
depressurizing the whole system and
emptying Water Works Hill
down to Fort Street. So, um this was
identified in our risk and resiliency
plan,
and um it's currently under design. Our
estimated cost is 1.1 million. That's
based on a 50% design. Um so, once we
get those costs finalized, we get a a
90% design and get it out to bid, we'll
be submitting legislation to enter into
a contract.
Okay. Any questions?
Thank you.
I'll add I made a mistake. I don't need
two readings, I need three readings.
Got that. Thanks.
All right, Amy will be my second on
that.
Change into three. Okay.
Any other questions? I know you Mr.
Ailes asked. Okay.
Temporary resolution 4526, also coming
through Water Water Pollution, Mr.
Ailes. Steven Wellstead is here to
discuss
45 and 46. You can just stay up there,
Steven.
Got you. Thank you. Good evening,
everybody. 4526 deals with the Frederick
Street sewer separation project. I've
been before you uh with previous
legislation on this project. This
legislation deals with just some of the
accounting things we need to do to make
sure that we can finance that project.
You may recall uh this project is being
financed with a loan through OWDA. It's
a reimbursement loan, so what's going to
happen is we will pay the contractor
when they submit their monthly pay apps,
we'll turn around, ask for reimbursement
from OWDA, who will give us what we just
paid back to us, back into the 1619 fund
that we're utilizing to pay for this
project. Uh so, again, everything here
is just ensuring that um we can account
for that revenue coming in, and then
also keep appropriations on the expense
side in line with the the funds we'll
have in in the proper account.
Happy to answer any questions if anybody
has any.
All right. Amy's my second on that one,
too. So.
And then 46.
For 46, this one deals with our next CSO
project, the Columbus Street and Wilson
Avenue sewer separation project up there
on North Columbus Wilson Avenue, just
south of Forest Rose uh cemetery there.
Um the this is just uh authorizing the
Service Safety Director to enter into
our contract for engineering services.
We recently did the uh
qualifications-based selection process
to determine the engineer uh based on
qualifications of the seven firms who
who submitted, we chose Verdant as our
top-scoring firm, and uh are going to
work on negotiating out to contract with
them. The intent with this legislation
is to um
basically authorize all contracts needed
through the end of construction, so that
would be uh not only design, but also
construction administration,
construction inspection, and any
preliminary studies necessary. Uh just
looking to get that done with one legis
piece of legislation here instead of
coming back multiple times at each of
those different phases.
And that project won't be started until
2027. That's correct. Yes. Correct.
That'll be next year's. Yes.
All right. That's three readings and Mr.
Bisjack will be my second.
Okay.
Any questions on that one?
What's the cost for both of these
projects? So, Frederick Street the cost
the amount noted in the legislation that
1.58 million that's the price that we
the low bid that we had with the
contractor at the bid opening March 2nd,
I believe.
Columbus Wilson is still too early to
tell.
We haven't without having design
engineer on board knowing the full
scope. I couldn't say. I know I've put
in some rough numbers for the purpose of
like a rate study I did a few years ago.
I'd have to go back and look at that. I
could look at what I assumed a couple
years ago when we when we did our rate
study for the stormwater utility, but
I would have to reference that in order
to give you something that is kind of
ballpark. Okay. Just for clarification
for anybody listening.
These are both projects we have to do
because of the state mandate, right?
>> Correct. Yes, as part of our NPDES
permit with Ohio EPA, we have various
projects we are required to undertake by
Ohio EPA to address the combined sewer
overflows that occur in the city and
both of these yeah are mandated on a
specific schedule. Okay.
Thank you. Yep.
Any other questions for Mr. Wellstead?
All right.
Thanks, Stephen. Yep, thank you all.
All right. I don't have any other
resolutions on here in front of me, so
we're going to move on to ordinances
temporary ordinance 926 that's coming
through public works.
Mr. Carr.
Yes, this piece of legislation is right
away acquisition for the East Main
Street sidewalk project and we have city
engineer Kurt Schoonk here to review the
project.
Good evening.
Uh this this allows us to
acquire right away for our East Main
Street sidewalk project that starts at
Ewing Street and goes out to the
community action.
Uh sidewalks on both sides. We're
widening the road a couple of feet on
each side of the road.
Most of the right away is
5 or 10-ft strips along the road
frontage of temporary or permanent right
away this so we can
push those curves back, have a little
bit of a tree lawn, and a 5-ft sidewalk.
Uh this next phase the right away
acquisition will probably take 12 to 18
months and then when we get that cleared
and get utilities moved, we can we can
build them probably in 2028-ish.
Any questions?
So, you allocated two and or 2 million
for this project, right? Is that correct
with a 10% match from the
>> That was our grant. We got a grant for 2
million dollars for the sidewalks. If it
doesn't all get used or is it possible
some of the allocated money will not get
used and if so, what could that go
towards?
Um it's it's too early to I think it'll
probably all get used. Our our total is
like 3 and 1/2 million for the whole
project. So, we've got some local
money that we'll have to match money
that we've got to come up with.
Um and it's
that grant is it has a very defined
scope. I don't think we could if there's
leftover money it probably goes back to
the state. State. Okay.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Uh Kurt real quick, so you said 2028
construction.
Right?
Yeah. Yeah, it it it could possibly
happen next year if the right of way
acquisition goes smooth, but there are
some tricky properties out there that
might take a while to negotiate.
What's the
what's the paving and when is
uh when is East Main on the paving
schedule?
Um it'll be 29 now.
>> Okay.
Yeah, it's
>> all of them are coming back around, but
so this will be done the goal is this is
done before
they come back through to do 22. Okay.
>> Yeah, we had to push the paving out one
year to make room for this. Okay.
Thank you. Any other questions?
All right.
Mr. Carr. Uh this will be a full three
readings and Ms. Smiley will be my
second. Okay. Thank you.
Temporary ordinance 1026 that is coming
through finance.
It is the city hall renovation
note for this year if uh
Ms. Nettles would like to
share some details.
>> as I spoke at the previous council
meeting that this is um
was coming back through. Um it is a when
it says the maximum it's a not to exceed
6.4
>> [clears throat]
>> million to renew for the city hall
renovations outside, but in discussions
with the mayor and service safety
director, we all came to
um the agreement to pay down some of
that principal up to about 10 10% down.
So, um we're going to be refinancing
five
5 million 800,000
rather than [snorts] the 6.4 that was
done this year. So, we're going to pay
down and borrow less on this um note. Uh
so, it's a one year 12-month note. So,
this time next year we'll be coming back
with another decision of what we're
going to do for future financing of
going through that. So, this is just
getting us through the construction
phase and this can go three full three
full reads.
Any questions on that one?
Okay. I have three readings Mr. Sully as
my second.
Uh any other ordinances that I'm not
aware of? I don't believe so.
So, before we go to department updates,
I'm just
>> [clears throat]
>> quick mathing here. We just went through
all those pretty quick and what is that?
Three, four, five, like 11 million
dollars worth of
worth of stuff. So, not all for this
year, but sometimes it's interesting to
look down through and see what we're
discussing. I know that we talk about it
ad nauseam and then these guys are like,
"Why are they blowing through it so
fast?" But we trust us, we have
discussed it uh whether it's at
committee or through emails and it seems
like we blow through it, but we have
all done our homework, I would hope. I
know the amount of meetings that we sit
in, you should have done your homework,
right? So, but it is a lot. So, anybody
has any questions,
always reach out to
the committee chair, anybody else. We're
all open for discussion just give a
little more background on those things.
So,
with that being said, I'm open to
department updates if we have any.
Mr. Fowler emerges.
Good evening, everybody. I just wanted
to provide a quick update since we have
uh some pending legislation for tonight
in regards to garbage truck. I have been
in communication with Isuzu Equipment
which has been in communication with New
Way. The truck that's not officially
ours because I don't have funding to
speak for it, but they're giving us
first right of refusal.
Um the truck has been the box itself has
been painted, chassis is ready, and
they've actually are mounting them
together as we speak.
And that truck hopefully will be in
Lancaster next week. So, as long as I
have funding to do so, we could
potentially late next week have that on
the streets. So, just quick update on
that.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Any other department updates?
All right. Seeing none.
Council meeting prep. As you can
probably already figured out, I'm
sitting in this seat because I'm running
the regular meeting. So,
quick council prep. We have a couple
presentations tonight. NOPEC.
Is that still on, Mr. Mayor?
Yes. Yep. Okay.
And then tree commission. I got a thumbs
up earlier on that one. So, we'll be
having those two.
Um everything else
looks fairly standard. So, with that
I'll kick it back to myself. Any other
discussion items for finance?
Seeing none, I will ask for a motion to
adjourn.
So moved. Second.
Motion and a second. We are adjourned at
6:17. The regular council meeting will
start probably at 6:30. Thank you.
The Frank [music] Smith Funeral Home and
Crematory in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community.
Feel free to give us a call at
740-653-0652. [music]
Stop in and see us at either of our two
locations. 405 North [music] Columbus
Street in Lancaster and 207 South Main
Street in Baltimore. Respect for [music]
tradition, regard for change.
Life moves fast and Buckeye is here to
keep you moving. New dream job?
Celebrate with a ride that feels just as
exciting. Passing the keys to your new
teen driver? Treat yourself to an
upgrade you'll love. Family getting
bigger? Buckeye's got the perfect,
spacious, safety-packed vehicle for
every new arrival. Wherever life takes
you, Buckeye Nissan, Georgesville
Nissan, Buckeye Honda, and Buckeye
Toyota are ready to drive you forward.
Your life, your car, your choice. Choose
Buckeye.
>> All right, everybody.
You if you've been here before when I'm
running these meetings, the gentle
reflection is about the art of
neighboring.
Uh so, I'm moving on to step two. Step
one, we kind of talk about get to know
your neighbors. You should know your
neighbors' names, right? So,
my suggestion or homework would be kind
of put a little more into it. So, why do
we want to do the art of neighboring?
Why is that important to me? It's it
actually
you know, brings on a little more sense
of community, safer.
You get to know your neighbors. You know
what's going on. You know what they need
help with, what they can help you with.
So, I just encourage everyone to kind of
move to that next step. Hopefully, you
know your neighbors' names.
How do we move on to the next one? And
then I'm also going to encourage you to
Uh so many people come to this meeting,
same group of people. Even if it's your
first time, come up to the podium. Take
your 3 minutes.
Tell [snorts] us who you are and why you
like to come to meetings. I'll give you
a good example. I'm on council. I wanted
to know I wanted to be in the know. Why
do we do these things? How can we help?
What needs changed? What needs What How
can I lend my hand, right? So,
we always would I'd love to hear why
everybody comes to the meeting. So, not
everybody all at once tonight, you know.
I keep it short like Please not
everybody decide that's a great idea.
I'm going to
we'll be here for an hour and a half.
But you know, you you get my gist. So,
if you if you're willing to share, we'd
love to hear that. So, with that being
said, uh everyone rise if they can and
uh join me in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I
>> pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America, and to the
republic for which it stands, one nation
under God, indivisible, with liberty and
justice for all.
Now, I'm going to call the meeting to
order. We are here for the
April 20th
Lancaster City Council meeting.
We will start with
roll call, please. Mr. Ailes?
>> Here. Mr. Bizjak?
>> Here. Mr. Carr? Here.
Ms. Colburn? Here.
Ms. Hook?
Here. Mr. Neisley? Here. Mr. Aug?
>> Here. Mr. Schoonover? Here. Ms. Smiley?
Here. And Mr. Solly? Here.
>> [snorts]
>> Mr. President.
Let the record reflect all 10 members of
council are here.
And Mr. Bizjak? Thank you, Mr.
President. I move that we excuse
President Porter tonight.
Second. Motion is second to excuse Mr.
Porter.
All those in favor signify by saying
aye. Aye.
Mr. Porter is excused. I just want to
point out for the record, this is the
second time I've covered for him and
we'll talk about three strikes you're
out type of thing, which I know is not
legal. It's just
my way to give him a hard time while he
watches.
>> [laughter]
>> All right.
Reading and disposing of the journal. I
have regular meeting minutes dated April
6th, 2026.
Mr. President.
Mr. Bizjak. I move that we receive and
file the journal. Second.
A motion and a second to
reading and disposing of the journal.
All in favor, please signify by saying
aye.
Aye. All opposed, same sign. Motion
carries.
Do we have any reports of city
officials?
>> I do. I have five this evening. I have
email dated April 7th, 2026 regarding
Lancaster Utilities collection due dates
submitted by Superintendent Molly Aspel.
Email dated April 9th, 2026 regarding
March 2026 collection report submitted
by Income Tax Commissioner Amy Hamilton.
Email dated April 16th, 2026 regarding
downtown cleaning on April 25th, 2026
submitted by Council Member Bizjak.
Email dated April 17th, 2026 regarding
background information on temporary
resolution
45-26
and 46-26 submitted by Stormwater
Manager Stephen Lawson.
Email dated April 20th, 2026 regarding
background information on temporary
resolution
44-26
submitted by Environmental Engineer Dean
Scroggs.
I move that we receive and file the
reports of city officials. Second. A
motion and a second to receive and file
the reports of city officials. All in
favor, please signify by saying aye.
Aye. All
opposed, same sign. Motion carries.
Do we have any communications? I have
two this evening. I have series of
emails between Law Director Hall, Emily
Zigler,
Council Clerk Scott dated and
Liz Fox um dated April 7th through
the 13th of 2026 regarding Marion
easement vacation.
Vacation.
Vacating. Let's just say that.
Word was not coming through. And then I
have mail dated April 9th, 2026
for liquor license permit 10008053-1
submitted by the Ohio Division of Liquor
Control.
Move that we receive and file the
communications, Mr. President. Second.
All right, we have a motion and a second
to
receive and file the communications. All
in favor, signify by saying aye.
Aye. All opposed, same sign. Motion
carries.
We do have two
presentations this evening. First from
NOPEC, second from the Tree Commission.
So, we will start off with
presentation from NOPEC.
Good evening.
Um thank you very much. My name is
Genevieve Costanzo and I'm a
representative from NOPEC. I'd like to
thank mayor and council for um inviting
me here today.
I am going to talk a little bit about um
your NOPEC aggregation and try to kind
of shed a little more color around what
we are and then answer any questions
that you all may have regarding this. Um
I have been with NOPEC [clears throat]
I'm going on my ninth year um and I am
just recently I have recently just
become the representative for Lancaster.
So, I'm really excited to be able to
work with you. It's only been a couple
months that I've been moved down here.
Before I directly start about NOPEC, um
I want to take just one minute to kind
of give you all a background. Um
So, we I I like to start off with saying
that in the year 2000,
Ohio decided to deregulate energy. That
happened in Columbus. Um there's only
about 10 states in the United States
that have deregulated energy. What
deregulating energy means is that they
separated the utility from your supply.
You cannot choose your utility. Your
utility is dependent upon where you
live. You have no choice over your
utility, but you do have a choice in
your supply.
That happened in the year 2000 in Ohio.
So, what happened is there were a whole
lot of right about 2001, 2002, there was
a whole lot of suppliers that came into
Ohio. And it got a little confusing for
certain people, you know, because this
whole idea of separating utility from
supply, it's not something that we are
all very familiar with, right?
So, what I like to do, if you don't
mind, is I gave all of you an AEP bill.
Um for the audience, I do have the bill
that I'm going to reference directly on
that table if any of you are interested
in following along.
Um but it's really important that we
know
as a council and as a community exactly
what we have agency over affecting as
far as our bill goes.
The first thing I ask you all to do when
you get your bill is to look at [snorts]
the page with the color wheel on it. The
color wheel is pink and blue.
To the right of that, you'll see a
graph.
It's very important. Now, this graph,
when you look at it, you'll see March of
2026.
It's very important first and foremost
to compare back 1 year. You want to look
March of 2026 and compare the graph to
March of 2025. You want to make sure
that they are in the same ballpark. This
right here is the first step in taking
control. You know that you have not left
a water pump out in the shed and it's on
the fritz as long as they're at about
the same level.
Right here, this bill, you used the the
customer used 768
kilowatts that month.
This is very, very, very important. The
kilowatts that you use each month, you
have control over, right? You can turn
your air condition off and save a whole
lot. You can unplug phantom um
appliances. There's a lot of different
ways that you could save energy. We also
do have some of those ways for your
reference on the NOPEC website.
>> [snorts]
>> So, right here, we know that we use 768.
Now, let's look at the second page and
look at the pink arrow on the left.
The pink arrow on the left is in your
energy choice zone.
Those charges right there are the only
thing that anybody in Ohio has any
control over.
I have done this for a long time and I
often see people kind of come up to me
with knots in their stomach because they
have a $200 bill and they only used 110
kilowatts that month.
Well, I said to them, and you have to
understand, the only thing that you
could control is the kilowatts you used
times the rate you have. And guys, rates
for electric are in cents.
This woman, 110 kilowatts,
right now, the going rate is about 10
cents.
Her supply bill was 11 What What was it?
110 * 10 cents $11. Her bill was $91.
The only part that any of us can control
is very simple. Kilowatts times your
rate. Your rate is in cents. It's about
8, 9, 10, 11 cents with the market.
We like to talk about that first because
it's very important that you understand
that. There's a whole lot of other
transmission and distribution charges.
You remember 5 minutes ago, I said Ohio
separated supply from the utility. All
the other charges are the utility,
transmission and distribution.
Okay, now we're going to go on.
Transmission and distribution, those
utility charges. The utility is
responsible for all of the over wires,
the grid, right? Or the under, the pipes
if it's gas. The utility is responsible
for um your bill, issuing your bill,
questions with your utility bill. The
utility is responsible if there is an
outage. These are all the regulated
utility, okay? NOPEC is not responsible,
or any supplier for that matter, is not
responsible for any of those things
listed. NOPEC is responsible for your
rate that's in cents. Now, I'm I say
that always because cuz when you look at
your gas rates, this is just on the
side, it's in dollars, but it's
important to know that kilowatts are in
cents.
So, going back to Ohio and we're now in
early 2000 when we know we've got the
utility charges separate from what we
have agency over, our supply, and we had
a lot of people getting really confused
about all the suppliers out there.
As a result of that confusion,
an aggregation was born. NOPEC was born
by 110 communities coming together and
they said, "I want an aggregation option
for my residents that they could just
have if they're confused, if they don't
really care.
I don't want them to have to try to
figure this out if they don't want to."
So, NOPEC got together not as a
for-profit retailer, which everybody
else is, and I'll we'll talk about that.
NOPEC is a council of governments
governed by an unpaid volunteer board of
directors, a representative from every
county we're in, and we are subject to
these same yearly auditing that every
single
count or every single city is by the
state of Ohio.
So, that's the basis of NOPEC. Now, what
they decided to do, NOPEC is an opt-out
program. We can talk about that in a
second cuz sometimes people have
questions about that. NOPEC is an
opt-out program, which means that if you
are eligible for NOPEC and you live in a
community that is a member of NOPEC,
you will get a NOPEC enrollment letter
every 3 years. That is mandated by the
Public Utilities Commission of Ohio.
Right now, some of you may have gotten
letters. Some of you may not have gotten
letters. The people who do not get
letters, who are eligible well, are
usually people who A, you have already
chosen your own supplier. We will never
take away your choice of your own
supplier. And if we did, we will get
fined big time. If you supply If you
chose your own supplier at sometime
during the game, you will not show up on
NOPEC's list. If you are on a percentage
of income a PIP plan or HEAP for gas, we
are not allowed to send you a letter, or
if you have gone to the PUCO and
permanently opted out, you will not get
a enrollment letter.
Now, NOPEC is something that is
perennial, which means by the state of
Ohio every 3 years, we will send you a
letter for electric letting you know
that we you are part of NOPEC and you
are in the electric program and giving
you an opportunity to opt out.
Now, it's very important to know A, you
can opt out anytime you want for free.
Anytime at all and you could call a
number 24 hours 7 days a week
anytime at all and opt out of NOPEC.
This re-enrollment letter is to advise
you
that you are eligible and you are
automatically in, but it's also and we
ask that you return if you want to opt
it out um in order to be to never have
NOPEC supply at all. Now, let's say that
you don't you miss the opt-out window.
You have a letter and it says, "Please
opt out." Well, if you miss it by 5 days
or 6 days, the worst thing that will
happen is that you may have NOPEC's
price for 1 month. That's the worst
thing. Because it all we work with meter
reads, right? So, we do the best we can
just to get you out as soon as your
meter read is available.
Talking about price.
NOPEC,
the aggregation
enjoys and is set upon, the foundation
is that we have bulk buying. We have 250
communities and that load is pretty darn
substantial. Because of that, when we
buy your supply, and for those of you
who are nerds, supply is traded on the
commodities market, right there with
corn. It goes up and down daily. We get
your supply and then or I'm sorry, we we
hedge your supply with a hedging
strategy and we come up with your rate.
We have The rate that you all are
getting is called our standard program
rate. Our standard program rate goes up
and down with the market.
Recently, um you guys got a letter and
your standard program rate is 9.99
cents, okay? So, that's times whatever
kilowatts you use, that's the only
portion that you can affect. The other
50, 60, 70% of the bill, you cannot.
9.99 cents is only for 3 months. The
reason it's only for 3 months is because
we have zero idea what is happening
right now with the commodity electric
market. Get We have none. It's going up
and down, up and down. If we were to
hedge you guys out a lot longer, you
would have had to were
it would have been a little bit higher
and so we got you the 9.99 rate. It will
change with your meter reading June. It
could very I'm sorry in August August,
the end of August.
It could go down. It often does
depending on where the market is or it
could stay the same. Last year it stayed
the same for an entire year or it could
go up slightly. The standard program
price goes up and down but it tries to
take out the peaks so you are not having
a 10 cent when a war starts and going
down to 5 cent the next month. Okay,
when something comes up. That's the
program price. However, if you don't
like the program price, we give you a
12-month fixed option or a 24-month
fixed option.
Those options came about because our
unpaid volunteer board of directors,
usually elected officials from every
county decided that our residents need
choices. Some of them want a 12-month
rate. Some of them want a 24-month rate.
Some of them want green energy and we
want you to be able to give them what
they want and we do and we also will
never have a termination fee for you
whatsoever and we will allow you to go
in and out so if you decide to go into a
24-month rate today
and come in September electricity is
near free or 3 cents, you could easily
get right out of it and you could go to
whatever the program is.
So these are all this is the way NOPEC
works.
Um
Let me make sure I have
NOPEC is opt-out and some people say
why? I don't think it should be opt-out.
It's opt-out because in order for an
aggregation program to work, you need to
have the critical mass and when you have
an opt-in program, they have modeled you
never reach that number to get
substantial savings. You just don't You
guys are very active here but there's a
lot of people who never even look at
their electric bill and they don't want
to know about this. So so aggregations
in Ohio are opt-out. We try to make it
as easy as we can by again letting you
call our customer service number at any
time.
Um
Okay, I think I probably missed
something but I am going to open it up
for questions now and if I think of
anything that I missed out, I'll add it.
Thank you.
Questions from council?
Anyone? I have one. Yes, ma'am. Ms.
Miley. Well, I just opened up my email
and my electricity went up 160 like 156%
and about threw my phone across the
room. [laughter] Yeah.
But that's a me problem. So when we're
talking about renewable programs
[clears throat]
>> Yes.
where does the renewable energy come
from? So what we do is we issue Rex and
then we retire the Rex. So we will buy
So the energy
can come from anywhere. It's basically
it
So it could be a plant down in Florida
but we are buying the Rex to continue
that and then we retire it once we buy
it.
Because in Ohio we don't have as much
green energy at this point. So that's
the way it works is we retire our Rex.
I could send you more information but
there is also a whole detailed three
pages of it on our website on how the
green energy works. Okay, thank you.
Yes. Mr. Bisjack. Thank you, Mr.
President. Just one question for you.
Um part of my ward is South Central, the
other part of my ward is AEP. Um so just
for clarifying for both folks that are
in both service areas
NOPEC only impacts the AEP service area,
correct? Not not South cuz as I
understand it South Central has a
completely different rate structure as
opposed to the investor-owned AEP. Yes,
thank you for saying that.
NOPEC only works with AEP, the
Illuminating Company. Um
First Energy. So thank you.
>> Thank you.
Duke. Yeah, not when it's a when it's a
co-op, we do not have anything to do
with that. We can't. Right. Just like I
said, I'm making sure for my my
constituents. Yes.
>> that.
Yes, sir. Mr. Yates. I I live on Lanreco
Boulevard. I live I've lived there for
38 years and 38 years I've lost power
more frequently living in town
than
probably anybody in this room. In fact,
as I was coming across town, my wife
texted me and said we're we've lost
power today, right now.
I never see any adjustment on my bill.
I've had power out for as long as a
week.
I've had power out for days. I've had
power out for hours. I never see an
adjustment on my bill. I'm I'm just
wondering why.
Well
in the beginning when I told you that
they separated the utility from the
supply um the only thing that any
supplier can
We have nothing to do with the utility.
The utility is solely responsible for
the lines, outages, your bill. They They
never took that part away from being
regulated.
>> Okay. It is regulated and again your
supply portion and the portion of your
bill that we're talking about today is
just that one arrow, the 768 * 9 cents.
>> But if I don't use power
you're saying that I can control my
kilowatts if I if I don't lose if I if
I'm not using it, why doesn't my bill go
down? That's a great question and I'm
going to tell you something that I found
out.
I was in one of my townships in
Ashtabula County and she went and got a
bill from the back and it was for one
light and she used 10 kilowatts, right?
Her bill was still $90.
She had $1.12
from us.
That has nothing to do Nobody can At
this point we have no agency over that.
That is controlled with the utility and
you set you set it, sir. Investor-owned
utility, they have to They're
accountable to shareholders. We are not.
We So anyway, that's all I'm going to
say about that. We have nothing
None of us can control the utility.
Well, actually I'm going to back up. I
thank you for saying that. One of the
things that NOPEC has done over the past
6 years is we have fought the utilities.
We have taken a legal team and we have
partnered with the Ohio Consumers
Council. Just recently, now this doesn't
affect you but recently we got a $270
million win because we said that some of
the base rate cases that the
Illuminating Company had put forward
were not fair. They were excessive to
each one of us and we won that. So
everybody in Now this is the key in the
Illuminating Company and I apologize got
a $27 credit over 3 months. Now about 5
years ago we worked and we also fought
against AEP for what we felt were
excessive charges and those are those
charges on that whole top part and we
won. It was only $18 million which
$18 divided by all these people comes up
to not very much at all, unfortunately,
like 10 $10. But you did see that as a
credit.
Yeah. Okay, thank you. You're welcome.
Just my opportunity to vent a little
bit. I understand. I hear it every day.
I'm not going to have dinner tonight so
you know
>> [laughter]
>> I I don't want to say too much about,
you know, the utility cuz that's not at
all us. So I can't really say too much.
So
Someone has beef with AEP. Question, Mr.
Carr.
>> Ironically, I just got a text from my
wife saying that the meeting she was
going to was canceled because the
power's out.
So Yes.
>> Timing was great. I understand. Yes.
Any other questions?
Ms. Nettles.
>> Sorry.
He's on council.
No, quick question. This is more for
anybody that has AEP and let's say they
have opted out because they didn't know
the difference cuz I have many
neighbors that, you know, the same way
of not knowing. They get this letter or
get contacted by an outside provider.
They're very
They work hard.
>> They're persuasive. They work hard um
and they've signed and they've done So
if they're listening and they say, oh
well, how do I opt back in? How do they
Oh, thank you so much. A great question.
The first thing I tell people to do is
to look at
your who is supplying you right now. So
look at that look at that company and
that is on the second page that we
looked at of your bill, right? Where I
told you was the only part that you have
agency over. Your supplier and their
phone number is there. The first thing
you need to do is you need to make sure
that if you chose to cancel that you
don't have any termination fees. I have
dealt I have had to sometimes counsel
some residents and say, I'm sorry, you
really need to just stick it out even
though it's at 15 cents because your
termination fee of $250 will not will
not wash. But so the first thing you do
is you call and make sure that you have
no termination fees and then you tell
that
that supplier that you want to go back
to the utility.
The reason and that sounds odd but the
reason is is that's how the process
works. The utility then marks your
account as shoppable meaning eligible
for aggregation and then within a one to
two billing cycle, the utility will
notify NOPEC, we will pick you up and we
will scoop you in by sending you an
enrollment letter.
Okay. Thank you. Um yes. Uh Mr. Neisly.
>> Yes, thank you.
Um yeah, I just I just wanted to say
first of all, thank you so much for
being here and for this education. I
know it's much appreciated. Um but my
question for you is um so you're saying
that uh the more people that are in this
program, the lower the cost could be for
everybody. Is that correct? I'm saying
that um we have the critical mass to
take uh when we do do our hedging that
we can buy at a larger amount. Mhm.
Okay, thank you. You're welcome.
Um now
you know, somebody will say, "Why aren't
you the lowest price every day?" If you
go to energychoice.gov.ohio,
they'll say, "Why aren't you the lowest
price?" We cannot be the lowest price.
It's simply impossible because of the
market. Every price that you see rate
that you see today very likely will be
different tomorrow. So there is no way
when you hedge, you're hedging at a
specific time. And trust me, we have
people who that's their sole
responsibility to every day look where
the weather is, look at the weather
forecast, look at the geopolitical,
and hedge the best rate that we can for
NOPEC. So that's the answer. We strive
to be in the bottom 5 to 10% of any um
any real offer. By real offer, I mean
not a 1-month offer with a $9.95 a month
um service fee, not an offer that says
you'll have a $250 termination fee. So
since we're talking about apples to
apples, the one thing that I want to
tell all of you, cuz I tell everybody,
and this is so so so important. When you
go to apples to apples to choose a
supplier, first of all, make sure that
they don't have a monthly fee. Second of
all, just don't get a termination fee,
okay? But the third thing that none of
you know about, and I just recently
after doing this for 9 years and seeing
so many people,
when you get a 12-month contract, do not
wait until the 12th month to call and
renegotiate because in my experience,
inevitably, month 13, your rate will go
up and sometimes substantially. If you
have a 24-month rate, do not wait till
month 24. Do it in month 23. Call them
up, renegotiate. If you're at 12 months,
do it in month 11. Stay on it, do not
miss it.
I'm going to end with this. In 2008, I
was home,
stay-at-home mom, somebody knocked on my
door, and they gave me an offer that I
thought was great. Didn't really know a
whole lot about energy.
I
3 months after that, I went back into
the workforce and got really really
busy. They sent me a postcard 12 months
later.
I threw it away. I mean, I was basically
staying above water, right? That was in
2009. I started working with NOPEC in
2018,
and was humiliated because and I didn't
tell anybody,
but I looked at my bill and saw that I
was paying $8.63
per MCF for gas
when NOPEC was charging $2.74.
9 years,
I didn't know
that's what happens. So it can happen to
anybody. I'm not stupid. It's just a
very It's a It's a It's I I like to
educate people, and I really want to
empower you guys to make your right
decisions, stay on it, know what you
need to know.
I think NOPEC is a great price. My
86-year-old grandmother, I say, "Go on
NOPEC. It will not expire. You do not
ever have to worry because even if you
get a 12-month or a 24-month, they're
not going to ever drop you back up and
triple you. They're going to put you
onto the standard program price, which
is also always a good price. So I say
you stay on it. I never have to worry
about what happened to me being happened
to you." All right.
Thank you very much. Got one more
question. Mr. Misjack. Sorry, Mr.
President, and thank you. You're
welcome. Um my last question for you is,
do you have any input at all in on
capital improvements or transmission
lines in terms of allowing for stable
energy trans electricity transmission?
Um
unfortunately, once again,
>> Yeah, I figured not.
>> we are very very limited. We you're
the the kilowatts you use times today
it's 10 cents. That's it. Nothing else.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you all so much. Um
Hold on. Sorry.
Ms. Nettles. I've got one more. Let's
say, I'm just trying to think for the
audience out there. They appreciate They
don't know that are they on NOPEC?
Aren't How are they going to know? And
looking at this, there's nothing says
you're on NOPEC.
>> You're right.
>> How are they going to know they're
either on or off? Well, you got me
because this sheet right here,
where I have the arrow, where I said is
the choice zone, Uh-huh.
the supplier is listed. I just had to
white it out because this was a bill
that my friend gave
us. So she
So but this is where it will say NOPEC
right here along with our phone. So you
can find out if it doesn't say NOPEC,
this is the other thing. Please, our
customer service number that I've
mentioned a few times, even if you're
not with NOPEC, they have your account
information. I do not. So
1-855-NOPEC-01.
24 hours 7 days a week, call 3:00 a.m.
Saturday morning, and you will get
somebody to answer you hopefully within
3 to 4 rings.
1-855-NOPEC-01.
They have your account information. They
can answer any more questions that you
have today,
and really set you straight. Set you on
the path that you want to be on. I just
wanted to say
Any other questions? Mr. Sully. Sorry,
one quick question. Do you Do you have
any ballpark numbers of what your the
savings is versus AEP for an average
>> Oh yeah, I'm so glad you said that. Um
so
what I
The number is Okay, so for Summit for
some caller, if you go to our website
nopec.org,
um you can look at the annual reports,
and that will show you a bar graph of
the NOPEC program price, not the 12 or
24 month, compared to um the price to
compare, compared to other um
>> [snorts]
>> offers.
But I do know that if you and
unfortunately, the stat I'm going to
tell you probably doesn't mean a hill of
beans to you because compared to um the
Illuminating Company, First Energy, if
you were on NOPEC, we saved 20% since
June of 2023 by being on NOPEC as
opposed to the price to compare. Now
that is albeit that's First Energy. So I
um don't know exactly AEP. They're
They're pretty Well, yeah. I'm sorry.
Dah, Jenny. This is new to me. Yes. So
it's the same cuz our prices are the
same. So 20% is your answer. Um
that being on NOPEC's program price has
saved you since June of 2023 compared to
being on the price to compare.
You're welcome. I apologize for that.
Any other questions?
Thank you very much. I'm going to sum
that up by this is a perfect opportunity
to take what you've learned
and do a little bit of what?
Neighboring. Yes. So every time the
renewal letter comes out, you see it on
Facebook of people get a little upset.
You do have a choice.
I have never switched off of the
aggregation because
you look at two spots on your bill, and
you can tell that you're getting a
cheaper price. So
if you got to show that bill to someone,
do that. And if they don't believe you,
move on, but you tried. That's the art
of neighboring that I'm talking about.
All right.
We have the tree commission next.
>> [laughter]
>> 5 minutes or less, please.
That's nice.
Just kidding.
All right, good evening. My name is
Brian Ebert, and I know that most of you
assume I'm up here to just complain
about infrastructure, but I'm here
tonight as a member of the tree
commission. So with some fellow tree
commission members, um so just some
background on the tree commission, the
city of Lancaster established a tree
commission in 1975 with the passing of
chapter 939 of Lancaster codified
ordinances,
um and that's been 51 years ago. Um out
of those 51 years, the city of Lancaster
has been recognized as a Tree City USA
by the Arbor Arbor Day Foundation for 44
consecutive years. And we have received
the growth award, which is above and
beyond just being recognized as a Tree
City USA for 9 consecutive years. Um we
have recently been working over the last
number of years with
uh Steve
um and new tree commission members and
the Ohio Department of Natural Resources
Division of Forestry folks, uh the urban
forester for our area to develop um more
SOPs, more standard operating
procedures. Namely, um we recently wrote
a urban forest man- urban forest
management plan. Um and from that, the
mission statement is that planning today
for tomorrow to maximize the economic,
environmental,
uh and social benefits of a sustainable
urban forest for the residents of
Lancaster, Ohio.
Uh we have a number of goals, six goals
from that to maintain the health and
vigor of all municipal trees in the
urban forest, to plant the largest
suitable tree for the site selected, to
maintain species diversity following
what's known as a 10-20-30 rule. So,
essentially to try to get ahead of pests
like emerald ash borer or some of the
other things that have wiped out entire
blocks or more of street trees. We don't
plant more than 10% of
the same species, 20% of the same genus,
or 30% of the same family within a
certain distance. We create and maintain
a tree inventory for all the municipal
trees and that's one of the things that
we're working on right now.
We want to achieve a 33% tree canopy
coverage and that includes both
municipal trees, those trees in parks,
trees in city right-of-way, trees in the
tree lawn, but also public tree I'm
sorry, private trees on an individual's
property. And then we want to achieve an
overall tree life expectancy of 75
years.
I'm going to turn it over to Mike. Yep.
I'm going to talk about a little bit
about why we must maintain the city
trees. So, there are the legal
requirements from the Ohio Revised Code
where basically to translate to dumb all
that down really quickly is political
subdivisions have a duty of care to look
for predictable failures that could
affect somebody or property. And that's
in all public grounds.
And then with that you would say, "Well,
we should just cut down all the trees
then we don't have that that problem."
But, there are a lot of benefits of the
urban forest. So, some of the current
numbers that we have, we have
approximately 6,700 street trees in the
city. And in the city limits, this is
public and private trees, there's an
estimated 286,000 trees.
Some of the ecosystem benefits that they
provide, the total annual benefit of all
those trees is $1.7 million.
The total canopy percentage that we
currently have as Brian said is 30.7,
but it prevents 30 million gallons of
storm water runoff per year.
It intercepts over 202 million gallons
of rainfall per year.
And it sequesters 4,360
tons of carbon per year.
Some of the other benefits that it has
is it benefits real estate, so it boosts
occupancy rates, adds curb appeal.
Consumer behavior.
Consumers make judgments about potential
shopping experiences based on tree cues.
It improves community character, it's a
more pleasant atmosphere, it's a
positive image. Customers are more
willing to travel farther, stay longer,
and visit more frequently.
For transportation, it's a buffer for
pedestrians.
Drivers prefer seeing roadside trees to
then just
nothing.
Adds
to a longer pavement life
and slower, more attentive driving.
It also
parking lot and hardscape issues. Trees
are often an afterthought which can
create drainage problems, urban heat
islands and less incentive for public
transportation. If you've ever waited
for a bus where there's no shade in the
middle of the summer, it's pretty
painful.
I've already talked about some of the
storm water benefits.
It also helps with brain health, boosts
concentration, improves your mental
health, and improved test scores, and
physical health. Adds to a walkable
community, healthier citizens, and
reduces health care costs.
Trees are really good investment.
They're the only piece of urban
infrastructure that appreciates in
value. Tree benefits increase as the
tree size increases.
So, the longer the tree lives, the more
benefits you get from that.
As Brian stated, we did work on the
urban forest management plan
and the big thing that we we received
this year
was the reimbursable grant from ODNR to
complete a street tree inventory and
site index.
This will identify all the city street
trees and planting sites available to
us.
And the action item two part of our plan
would be to create a citywide planting
plan. So, we would have that in place
and it would be simple as we can plant
trees in all those spaces as money
allows.
And identifying all these city street
trees will allow staff to become more
proactive instead of reactive. Tree care
is a lot more affordable when trees are
smaller and maintenance is planned
versus emergency work. And we've noticed
over the last couple of years that since
Justin, the city forester, has started
that a lot of that emergency work is not
happening after these big storms. We
haven't had to have tons and tons, it's
been decreasing over over time.
And then the last thing, so Steve, park
superintendent, is the municipal
arborist.
Justin, who I stated earlier, is the
city forester. He's an ISA
track certified arborist which means
he's International Society of Arborists
and then he's tree risk assessment
qualified. So,
really knows his stuff. And we have
another full-time
arborist and a part-time. And that's
who's taking care of all the city trees
which is a lot of trees, especially when
you talk about the parks.
I've been on tree commission for 1
month, so
hello. And I'm grateful that I didn't
have to remember all of that and I'm
more here for support it feels like.
But, to wrap it up, my part is basically
to say if you have a tree lawn and you
want a tree in it, let us know. We will
have someone come out, we'll look, we'll
see what size tree we can get on there,
we'll see if we have that tree
available, how we can pay for that tree.
Um
but we also want to recognize that it's
not just planting new, we also need to
maintain the ones that we have. So, we
would like more engagement from the
community and if you have questions
about how to maintain the trees or what
the tree commission does, reach out to
one of us.
>> [clears throat]
>> Particularly Brian.
Seems to have most of the answers.
But, he's by far the grumpiest. And I
guess I would say thank you very much
for letting us
talk. Arbor Day is on Friday.
I know some tree commission members will
be at the Seeds of Change at the
fountain on Saturday.
Fountain Square.
Perfect.
Thank you.
>> have to remember all that. I did kind of
encapsulate it in some handouts, so you
can look at those.
I thank you.
Do we have any questions from council
for the tree commission? I just have
one. If we notice areas within our like
our neighborhoods that we think trees
should
would be helpful, how would we
get on this plan that you're developing?
So, right now the plan we're using like
a scientific based approach. So, tree
lawns have to be a minimum of basically
4-5 ft wide to plant a small tree. Large
tree species like your oaks
would need way bigger tree lawns. So, I
know like downtown is very small, has
very poor soil. So, if we're kind of
limited on some of some of those things,
but we can amend the soil and then plant
trees in those sites.
And we're working on getting a fillable
online fillable form that'll be on the
city website so that if you have a tree
related problem or if you would like a
tree in an area, you can fill out the
form and it'll go to tree commission and
we can kind of get that put on there.
The form is on there now, it's just not
fillable. Yeah. submitted that way, you
have to print it, but there is a form so
you can fill that out and send it in.
Any other questions, Mr. Carr? I would
just like to say that we've been very
appreciative of working with Justin
because we have
had three of those 75-plus year old
trees.
Lost one last year, they were very great
they were great at taking it out, but
they've been very very very diligent in,
you know, working with us to to keep
those alive and around as long as they
could.
One was replaced last year and I
anticipate we'll have another spot for
you at the end of this year probably.
So.
Any other questions?
Seeing none, we thank you all for being
here. Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
All right.
We're going to re-engage on the agenda.
Do we have any petitions and memorials?
There are none this evening.
All right. Do we have any voters or
taxpayers that would like to come up and
address council? If so, this is the
time.
I'll give you the quick rundown. State
your name and address for the record and
you have 3 minutes. Yes, I'm so glad
that I signed up today since it was like
a homework assignment. My name is Amy
Schlaik. I live at 763 Lancaster
Boulevard. Yes, we did lose power today.
It's back on just so you know. Um Good.
>> [laughter]
>> But, I'm here because
members of council, because I wanted to
thank Steve with Parks Department. They
worked with in collaboration with
parents and with the Southeastern Ohio
Center for Independent Living
to um
work with us to make a Monday Funday
event that we will have on a monthly
basis for individuals with
various needs, special needs,
where they can come together. So, our
first one was adaptive karaoke which
really is just sing along with the words
so that
music is still happening and nobody's
sitting there judging if you don't get
the right word at the right time. And
so,
we had a good turnout, it was a lot of
fun. Our next one's going to be a bingo
night. I've I've had just this past week
two different phone calls with parents
of individuals with special needs
at different ages looking to try to get
them a support group, a friend group, a
social network, someplace so that
they're doing something.
One of them lasted for an hour, one of
them lasted for 2 and 1/2.
And so, this is needed
whether you know it or not, and I
appreciate that they took a step to hold
my hand and help me get it started.
Um
Backing up, I also want to thank you for
the ramps because accessibility is
opportunity and opportunity changes
possibility. And I just want to say that
SoSo's doing
magnificent job. They're here in town
down on Broad Street, but they're also
down in Athens. And Athens is not doing
so well with
>> [laughter]
>> their accessibility, and they've been
proclaiming that very loudly with
[clears throat]
reports and videos and things like that.
So, just so you know, thanks. That's
appreciated by myself, by SoSo, and um I
just want to say thank you.
Good things are coming. That's why I
show up, by the way, so that I know the
people to ask to help me with things
that I need to do.
>> To be in the know.
>> Yes. There you go.
There's more than in the know than on
Facebook.
And it's
It's in this room. Okay?
But Facebook in the know is definitely
something. Hi, my name is Eli Shlaik.
It's definitely interesting, y'all. That
is my mom back there. I am at 338 and
1/2 Harrison Avenue, and happy that the
power's back on. Like, you be.
So, I kind of wanted to follow up where
she left off. Next Monday Funday is
Bingo Night.
If I can check and see, 5 to 7:00 p.m.
May 18th at the Parks Building. Thank
you, Steve. It's already gone.
That's ridiculous. Okay.
But, why I come to these is because I am
a member of the Rainbow Alliance of
Fairfield County, and I very much
appreciate that board. I got on it
because I was here about 2 years ago I'm
talking to you all, and you were too.
That was a fun time. If you all
remember, I think that was the most
people ever in this room, potentially
ever.
Amanda, we have the Destination Downtown
Cleanup Day coming up. So, if you want
something to do for Arbor Day, you
should go see that. Go see her. Wink
wink, nudge nudge.
>> [laughter]
>> Um we're going to have a couple other
things coming up. We've got our Pride
Brunch. I want to see some of you there,
all of you there, whoever wants to show
up, okay? Come on down. We're going to
have some mimosas, so cheers, guys.
Um we're going to have Light the Night
Pride as well coming up in September, so
I hope to see you guys there.
Thank you guys so much for what you do,
and thank you for helping us out when
you get the chance.
Good evening, members of council. I feel
like so many people have been pitching
Downtown Cleanup Day, but I'm still
going to make the ask here of all of
you.
I know you've got a city to run, so I
will try and keep this short. I'm still
getting over a little bit of the pain
from Mike Szulczewski saying that
downtown has bad soil. So, my soil is
feeling offended. I'm offended. My soil
is fine. My soil is fine. Don't judge my
soil. Um
Destination Downtown Lancaster is
hosting its annual event, Downtown
Cleanup Day. We're super excited that
this year we can combine it with the
Seeds of Change, which will be happening
at the fountain. But, if you'd like
something to do this weekend, we'd love
to see
some of you who help shape our city out
there helping it shine, too. We meet at
the gazebo at 8:00 a.m. rain or shine,
although the Weather Channel does say it
will be a balmy 59°
and the chance of rain is low from 7:00
a.m. through noon, and we are always
done by noon. So, this is kind of your
chance to trade in these council
chambers for some work gloves and swap
motions for some mulch, and show
residents that civic pride looks just as
good in jeans as it does behind that
dais.
We'll provide the supplies, the
projects, and plenty of appreciation.
And because public service should come
with a few perks, we are going to give
all of our volunteers a free Downtown
Cleanup Day t-shirt. You'll get a coupon
for $2 towards a coffee or a beverage
any of our downtown locations. And
thanks to the Hutch, thanks to Brad
Hutchinson, everyone who volunteers that
day will get a lunch coupon to be used
at any of the downtown lunch spots.
That's valued up to $13. So, you can
come, build community,
practice in the art of neighboring.
Thank you,
Corey. So, join us and show your
constituents that you care about the
center of civic life and you are
downtown.
Think of it as bipartisan
beautification.
Sign up tonight. I You if you check your
council emails, you've got a link for
sign up and a description of the event.
And let's prove that when Lancaster
rolls up its sleeves, great things can
happen. We're going to get a little
dirty, and we're going to do a lot of
good, and I hope to see all of you out
there. You know, some of you may be
campaigning soon. It's great photo op.
I'm just saying. Thank you very much.
First off,
um
talking a little bit more about DDL. In
case none of you around here
know it, volunteers water the flowers
every day downtown. Volunteers plant the
flowers every day.
Or not every day.
The beginning. We We plant three
different three different plantings.
Um my point to come up here is to urge
you to sign up. Uh you can contact DDL
or contact myself. We need folks to
water.
Uh we put out the 4 months of watering
schedule, so we need to get you on that
schedule. Last year, if I remember
correctly, we had 75 volunteers.
They have to be I'm going to reiterate.
They have to be watered every day.
Um then the other thing that I wanted to
talk about, I wanted to thank everyone
of the um express my thanks and
gratitude to the Code Enforcement Zoning
Committee for not bringing forth the
legislation on the feathered flags. Um
as we spoke uh as I spoke 2 weeks ago
here and then in the committee,
um I I thank you for considering um
that it is a safety concern.
I want to thank Andrew Lindell from the
Building and Codes Department. He's
always a wealth of information. Thank
you.
Thank you, Ms. Bobbitt.
Anyone else want to come up and share?
Seeing none, we will move on to
reports of standing committees, please.
I have six of them this evening. Water
Water Pollution Meeting Agenda dated
April 8th, 2026 submitted by Mr. Ills.
Code Enforcement and Zoning Committee
Meeting Agenda.
Um dated April 8th, 2026 submitted by
Mr. Sully.
Safety Committee Meeting Minutes dated
April 12th, 2026 submitted by Mr.
Szulczewski.
Law Committee Meeting Agenda dated April
14th, 2026
submitted by Ms. Smiley and
Law Director Hall.
Public Works Committee Meeting Agenda
dated April 15th, 2026 submitted by Mr.
Carr and Operations Manager Charlie
Mullet.
And Finance Committee Meeting Agenda
dated April 17th, 2026 submitted by Mr.
Skundric.
Mr. Szulczewski. Thank you, Mr.
President. I move that we receive and
file the reports of standing committees.
Second.
A motion and a second to accept and file
reports of [clears throat] standing
committees.
All in favor, please signify by saying
aye.
Aye. All opposed, same sign. Motion
carries.
Any reports of special committees?
>> There are no reports this evening.
We have no public hearings this evening,
so we did not hit the trifecta as per
usual when I'm sitting up here.
So, we are going to move on to reading
of resolutions beginning with the third
reading of temporary resolution 3826.
A resolution authorizing the mayor to
act on behalf of the City of Lancaster
and enter into any and
enter into any and all agreements or
settlements necessary to participate in
the new national opioid settlements with
the Associated Pharmacies Incorporated
and American Associated Pharmacies, J.M.
Smith Corporation, Louisiana Wholesale
Drug Company Incorporated,
um Morrison Dickson Company, North
Carolina Mutual Wholesale Drug Company
Incorporated, and United Natural Foods
Incorporated including its subsidiaries,
Supervalu and Advantage Logistics, and
to declare an emergency. This is through
the Law Committee, Ms. Smiley and Mr.
Rock. Ms. Smiley.
Yes, thank you, Mr. President Pro Tem. I
would like to make a motion that City
Council pass, engross, and enter upon
the written record resolution
temporarily numbered
38-26.
Second.
We have a motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 3826. Any
discussion? So, as a reminder, this is
asking council to approve a city
settlement and release of claims from
those six remnant defendants as part of
a multi-district litigation, and that is
the national opioid
claims settlement. In a previous council
authorized a previous law director to
participate, and the city did. So, now
we have the opportunity to recover those
funds from those six defendants
um that worked out a potential
agreement. So, we would be voting to
agree and authorizing the city
to join the settlement group and receive
funds from those defendants, and the
defendants are the opioid
distributors.
Very well, thank you. Any other
questions or comments?
Seeing none, please call the roll. Mr.
Eells?
>> Yes. Mr. Bizjak?
>> Yes. Ms. Carr?
>> Yes. Ms. Cohen? Yes. Mrs. Hook? Yes. Mr.
Nicely? Yes. Mr. Ogg?
>> Yes. Mr. Schoonover? Yes. Ms. Smiley?
Yes. And Mr. Sully?
>> Yes.
Motion carries
10 to 0.
So, all for third readings of
resolutions, moving on to the second
reading of resolutions with temporary
resolution 40-26. A resolution to
appropriate from the unencumbered
balance and amend the certificate of
appropriations with the county auditor
in the sanitation fund 6005
for the purchase of a new front load
garbage truck and to declare an
emergency. This is through service
committee, Mr. Nicely and Mrs. Hook.
>> [snorts]
>> Mr. Nicely. Yes, thank you, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion
that council suspend its rules and waive
the third reading of resolution
temporarily numbered 40-26.
Second.
We have a motion and a second to suspend
the third reading of temporary
resolution 40-26. Discussion? Yep. Thank
you, Mr. President.
As we heard in finance just a little bit
ago, this this passing this resolution
tonight will allow the city sanitation
department to take ownership of a new
front load garbage truck as soon as next
week.
Great. Any other discussion?
Seeing none, please call the roll. Mr.
Eells?
>> Yes. Mr. Bizjak?
>> Yes. Ms. Carr?
>> Yes. Ms. Cohen? Yes. Mrs. Hook?
>> Yes. Mr. Nicely?
>> Yes. Mr. Ogg? Yes. Mr. Schoonover? Yes.
Ms. Smiley?
>> Yes. And Mr. Sully?
>> Yes.
Motion to suspend passes 10 to nothing,
Mr. Nicely. Yes, thank you, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion to
pass and engross and enter upon the
written record resolution temporarily
numbered 40-26.
Second.
We have a motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 40-26. Any other
discussion? Uh yeah, Mr. President,
thank you. Just to just to remind
everybody,
this legislation is necessary because
there was a front load garbage truck and
sadly it was the newest truck in the
fleet was involved in an accident back
in February.
The sanitation department has been
renting a front load garbage truck ever
since at the cost of $8,900 a month. The
repair bill
almost a month ago now was at about
$128,000
with with some cost outstanding, some
hidden damage, and things like that. So,
I'm sure that estimate has gone up. And
so, this legislation is just to fund the
the cost of the rental until we got this
purchase the new vehicle and to cover
the cost of the purchase of the new
vehicle.
All right. Thank you. Any other
comments?
Mr. Ogg. Just one thing while I'm
that came to mind, the initial garbage
truck was in an accident. Was there
any insurance or anything? Obviously, we
haven't been insured, but
any idea what that would have covered
and
offset
>> I I I don't know if if Superintendent
Fowler, if you if you have anything to
add to this, but my understanding is
that
insurance had not completely totaled the
truck yet and they were still working on
how much the damage was going to cost.
And so, that's my understanding, but
Superintendent Fowler, if you have
anything to add? Yeah, sure. So,
unfortunately, still at this moment, I
was just chatting with earlier with
Law Director Hall, we're still working
through the insurance. So, as we're
doing all that, we're still paying
$8,900 a month for a truck. And if we
were to add a place where we could start
that today, the there's 222 plus
man-hours that are going to go into the
repair of this truck. We wouldn't see
this truck for 10 months. So, it is
insured. Right now, they've issued us a
repair check for $74,000
and I had the truck at Peterbilt and
they found the damage to be 128 with
frame damage and other hidden damage
that they couldn't get to because the
engine and transmission has come out of
it. And we still haven't even got the
insurance to yet give us the 128. So, it
was kind of a factor of everything,
especially considering we'd be spending
in basically $107,000
in this time for a rental that
doesn't accomplish anything. Well, it
gets the route done, but we're kind of
set burning that money in the backyard,
basically. Hopefully, that answers your
question. Was the city at fault
in that wreck or
>> The driver, believe it or not, it was a
four-man-hour collision with a utility
pole.
He was backing out of a location and
went to then turn to make the turnout
and the arms when they come down that
lift the dumpster was blocking his view
to a pole and he had turned into that
pole. So, the you know, the the truck
and the full of trash weighed about
50,000 and the utility pole did not move
and it moved the dash in the truck 10 in
along with the steering wheel and broke
steering and bent frame and
So, it was yes, it was was our fault,
but it was literally a we have full
video of it. It's literally a
four-man-hour collision.
Any other questions?
Seeing none,
we're at
roll call, aren't we? Yeah.
Sorry. Please call the roll. Mr. Eells?
>> Yes. Mr. Bizjak?
>> Yes. Ms. Carr?
>> Yes. Ms. Cohen? Yes. Mrs. Hook? Yes. Mr.
Nicely?
>> Yes. Mr. Ogg?
>> Yes. Mr. Schoonover? Yes. Ms. Smiley?
Yes. And Mr. Sully? Yes.
Motion to pass temporary resolution
40-26
passes 10 to 0.
All right.
On to first readings of resolutions
beginning with temporary resolution
41-26. A resolution to authorize the
mayor to enter into a contract with the
Fairfield County General Health District
for the public health services. This is
through finance committee, Mr.
Schoonover and Mr. Eells.
That's me. First of three readings.
Temporary resolution 42-26.
A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of appropriations with the
county auditor in the general fund fund
for the retirement within the Lancaster
Fire Department and to declare an
emergency. This is through safety
committee, Mr. Bizjak and Mr. Ogg. Mr.
Bizjak.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. It's the first
three readings.
First of three readings on temporary
resolution 42-26. Temporary resolution
43-26.
A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of appropriations with the
county auditor in the .15 fire levy fund
and to declare an emergency. This is
through safety committee, Mr. Bizjak and
Mr. Sully. Mr. Bizjak. Thank you, Mr.
President. Also, this is the first of
three readings. First of three readings
on temporary resolution 43-26.
Temporary resolution 44-26.
>> A resolution authorizing the service
safety director to advertise for bids
for the South Water Plant backflow
valves project and to declare an
emergency. This is through water and
water pollution control committee, Mr.
Eells and Ms. Cohen. Mr. Eells. First of
three readings, please. First of three
readings on temporary resolution 44-26.
Now, temporary resolution 45-26.
A resolution to increase receipts,
appropriate funds from the storm water
utility reserve 600 fund 6019, amend the
certificate of other sources and
appropriations with the county auditor
and authorize payments of bills within
and now certificates for the Ohio Water
Development Authority loan for the
Frederick Street sewer separation
project. This is through water and water
pollution control committee, Mr. Eells
and Ms. Cohen. Mr. Eells. First of three
readings, please. First of three
readings on temporary resolution 45-26.
Temporary resolution 46-26. [snorts]
A resolution authorizing the service
safety director to enter into a contract
for engineering services on the Columbus
Street and Wilson Avenue sewer
separation project. Again, this is
through water and water pollution
control committee, Mr. Eells and Mr.
Bizjak.
Mr. Eells. First of three readings,
please.
First of three readings on temporary
resolution 46-26.
Are there any other resolutions
to come before council this evening?
Seeing none, we'll move on to the
reading of ordinances beginning with the
third reading of temporary ordinance
7-26. An ordinance to accept the final
plat for the Victory Commons
development. This is through code
enforcement and zoning committee, Mr.
Sully and Mr. Nicely. Mr. Sully.
Thank you. Mr. President, I'd like to
make a motion to pass and engross and
enter upon the written record
ordinance temporarily numbered 7-26.
Second.
We have a motion and a second to pass
temporary ordinance 7-26. Discussion?
This is the two legislation is to accept
the final plat for the Victory Commons
development, which is apartments
out on Election House Road
and units that this city desperately
needs.
All right. Thank you. Any other
discussion? Mr. President, um
>> Mr. Nicely. I think I remember a
previous council meeting we did we
talked when we were mentioning or
talking about this ordinance that it was
to allow for uh the the the easement or
whatever necessary to have sidewalks
placed along the the project. Is that
correct?
I
think it was actually more than that. It
was the
for the utility the where the final
right-of-ways for utilities and and we
could have somebody come forward. Um
Chaz and I can
>> correct. That's what a subdivision plat
is. It's for the dedication of easements
and
uh right-of-way for public use.
Um sometimes there are variances, if
that's what you're asking about, but
those are typically granted by the
planning commission um or depending on
what kind of variances it is, it could
be a uh
issue that's heard by the BZA, but that
all gets done before it gets to planning
commission for review of the final
subdivision plat. You're just reviewing
the final subdivision plat here. All
right. So, to answer his question, it
was the turn lane cuz I think the
original legislation had a showing a
turn lane or something in it.
>> thought it was that or sidewalk.
>> that's what I had seen in that, too.
And is that was that not this one? It
was a different piece.
>> No, yeah, I'm not sure what you're
referring to, but this is just the
Victory Commons subdivision final plat.
>> Okay. Yeah, I think that plat did show
the turn lane in the previous one,
didn't it? So.
I I apologize. I don't know, but the
city engineer approves all of those. So,
it would it would be whatever our
standard is and whatever the the terms
and conditions
>> we had an attachment one of the handouts
that was showing the turn lane that Mr.
Knisely's referencing. So, I will make
sure we're talking about the right one.
I'm sorry. I wasn't following all of
that. Um the final plat is a dedication
of right-of-way on Election House
for the widening and the turn lanes.
It's also dedicating um some
right-of-way to the county along uh
County Road 33 on on Memorial Drive.
Um
and the plans have all been approved.
The the apartments are being built.
Um we need this right-of-way now to keep
the the road. They'll start that this
summer.
Uh they'll start the construction of
that turn lane and we'll need this
right-of-way to
to uh occupy our our new roadway.
>> Okay. So, this piece is specifically
regarding the the right-of-way and the
turn lane stuff. Yes. Okay. Yep. That's
what Mr. Knisely was asking. I do have a
follow-up, Mr. President.
Uh I just want to say that um
you know, I I think if we are going to
have this this uh
this uh apartment building, I think that
they they need these the road needs
these improvements. However, I just want
to make it clear for the record that I
do not support the underlying project.
Thank you, Mr. President.
Any other
questions?
Comments?
Seeing none, please call the roll.
Mr. Ailes?
>> Yes. Mr. Bissett?
>> Yes. Mr. Carr?
>> Yes. Ms. Cowan? Yes. Mrs. Hoop? Yes. Mr.
Knisely?
>> Yes.
Mr. Aug?
>> Yes. Mr. Skinover? Yes. Ms. Smiley? Yes.
And Mr. Sully?
>> Yes.
Motion to pass temporary ordinance 726
carries 10 to 0.
We have no second readings of
ordinances, so we'll move on to first
reading of temporary ordinance 926. An
ordinance to authorize the mayor to
acquire permanent and temporary
right-of-way as necessary for the East
Main Street shoulder widening and new
sidewalks projects known as the East
Main Main Street FAI-US
22-15.58
project. This is through public works
committee, Mr. Carr and Ms. Smiley. Mr.
Carr?
Nothing to add uh other than what was
presented in finance. This is the first
of three readings. First of three
readings on temporary ordinance 926,
temporary ordinance 1026. An ordinance
providing the issuance and sale of notes
in the maximum principal amount of
$6,400,000
in the anticipation of the issuance of
bonds for the purpose
of paying the cost of the renovation and
rehabilitation of the City Hall building
and otherwise improving the site
therefore, together
with all necessary appurtenances thereto
and declaring an emergency.
This through finance committee, Mr.
Skinover and Mr. Sully.
And this will be the first of three
readings on temporary ordinance 1026.
Um I'm not aware of any other ordinances
to come before us this evening.
We have no tabled legislation.
Is there any unfinished business that we
would like to discuss?
Seeing none, I'll entertain any new
business. Um Mr.
pro tem. I do have one that I received
in the mail. It's a liquor license for
Zap N Go Mart LLC, permit number
10018053-1.
This is a new license at 502 North
Columbus Street.
Okay.
Are you going to discuss that
more next time? This is the first time
I've heard of it and I don't know what
the due date is. I apologize. So.
>> is the due date. 5/2 is the due date.
Well, then no. We have
If you're making a decision,
5/2 is the due date? I do have a
question about this.
Yeah, so everyone got an email, right?
You sent this out in the email. So, this
is
new.
Law Director Hall, is this the building
that has a for sale sign on it now when
I drove past it today?
I don't know. 502 North Columbus is what
I'm hearing.
Correct. If I
I never received anything. Yeah, Mr.
Bissett. Uh to address your your
question, Council Member Smiley, I
believe this is the property that was
the old Olympic Games or Olympus Games
or something like that. It's the flower
shop structure.
So, I just wanted to throw that out
there. Yeah, it it's now a quickie
place.
I
don't know.
So, this is new
Zap N Go Mart.
So, it's Okay, so it's the one that
they've been working on for a while. So,
it's supposed to be a
Quick Mart
similar to
like what just went in on West Fair
Avenue. Yes. In the old Riches. Mhm.
General idea. I think so. Yeah, okay.
Yeah. I have no information. The police
department didn't send anything that I
was included on, so I apologize. I don't
know anything about it other than um
you know, it it looks like it's a
a convenience store.
It is crazy they give us 30 days to
and by the time we get it, it's 20 some
day 20 days. Okay.
I So, we have to
do something with it.
>> have to do anything.
>> Or not anything.
>> Yeah, you don't have to do anything. You
can you can vote to agree, you can
object, or you can just not do anything
and then the liquor permit will
automatically go into effect. Um as you
know, as they follow get through the
process with the Division of Liquor
Control.
>> [snorts]
>> Law Director Hall, what happens if we
approve it, but it is
being sold or it's for sale or it's for
lease or some there's a sign that I
thought I saw in front of it as of like
a day or two.
>> in the window that the owner has it for
sale. Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> So, liquor permits are um transferable,
they're movable. Um
the Division of Liquor Control gets to
decide how, where, when, all of that
good stuff. You don't really control
that. Um
if there's a transfer to another owner,
then you would have another opportunity
to weigh in on that for the liquor
permit itself, um but not for the
building, not for the underlying
building.
Mr. Ailes?
>> So, there's no liquor permit there now.
It's It's been a store, but it's been
many things, but lately it's been a
store, but there's no liquor permit
there. That's what we're hearing. Yeah,
this says new. Yeah, it says new.
>> It seems like they might have been
advertising that stuff. I don't know. Um
just from going by there.
I didn't know they were open. No. So,
okay. Any other questions, Mr. Aug? Um
Oh, sorry. If we object, is this just us
saying we think it's a bad idea, the
state still has the ability to issue it,
or
does this kill it here? No, if we
object, it goes to a hearing. The
Division of Liquor Control has to give
the permit holder
um due process. And so, it would go to a
hearing just like we requested on that
other one. Um
still haven't got any notice on that, by
the by, but um at the hearing, we would
go into um explain the city's side of
it, why the city believes that it's a
bad idea for a new liquor permit to be
issued, um you know, based on the
location or the owner um or any other
kind of
maybe zoning or code enforcement issue
that we would be aware of at the time.
Um and then after that hearing, the
Division of Liquor Control would make a
decision and inform everybody all the
parties of their decision and that's
what controls essentially.
Any other questions?
Mr. Knisely? Yeah, thank you, Mr.
President. Um Law Director Hall, it says
here on I'm looking at the paperwork. It
says they want they're they're applying
for a C1 and a C2 permit. Do you have
any idea what those permits are?
I apologize. I I have the permits um
memorized, but if you Google it, you can
just locate the the different types of
permits. They show up.
Also, the division of
the division of liquor control's
website, if you go on there and put in
the name of the
>> [snorts]
>> um
of the permit,
it will say what kind of permit class
they're looking for and it explains
those permit classes as well.
Thank you. Yep.
Any other questions?
Any
thoughts on a motion?
I I just want to make a point. One of
the things that concerns me is we get
these are presented to us
and I've never seen like a background
run on any of the
of the petitioners or or and and I don't
know if it's normal or it just I find it
disturbing. Uh
Yeah, so liquor control is responsible
for that and if you read the letter that
goes along with it, it says contact your
police department or county sheriff Um
we also sent them a detailed ownership
information to review for any criminal
background issues involving the
disclosed persons. Um so we're supposed
to get a background check. We're
supposed to get that information, but
the chief of police and I have both had
issues
getting it at the police department and
then when I've called later to request
it because he didn't get it, um they
tell me that they'll send it, but it
probably won't get there in time for us
to make a decision about the the pending
permit. Um so yeah, it's not a real
user-friendly um
process,
but
you know, like I said, that it's up to
the state of Ohio and up to the division
of liquor control how they handle that.
Um I agree it would be nice to have that
information and the letter says they're
giving us that information, but we're
not getting it.
So maybe some background on the business
that's going in or what they plan on
doing other than hey, we want a liquor
license, you know, would be
Yeah, I don't think they actually give
that kind of information. It's just more
the name of the individual that's tied
to the permit, um you know,
whether they have any criminal history,
um whether they have any other history
with the division of liquor control,
that kind of thing, which is, you know,
helpful information that it would be
nice to have when asking you all to make
a decision. Um I was just going to say
though
did you have any opportunity to get
signed up with the division of liquor
control to get online notices? I have
reached out to them several times and I
don't have any information back from
them. I'm not surprised. I opened a case
as well and I don't have any information
either. I I will attempt tomorrow to do
something better for you, but I
apologize. I you know,
we can only do what they will help us
do.
Go ahead.
Mr. Carr. We basically have no basis to
object or to agree with this.
So
what's what's the purpose of the
decision? I mean we can't we were yes.
What's what's the safest thing to do? Do
nothing.
I say
>> thing to do is to object. Yeah. And and
And then bring it to a hearing. And then
go to the to do the to do the back
Right. ground And that's not So
yeah.
So Mr. Augie, you have a question? Uh
I was going to make a motion to object.
All right, before before we do that,
just I just wanted to get one more
question from the law director.
You're okay. Um
so if there's a motion to object and
then they have a hearing that the city
presents its
reasoning for objection, how long did
you know how long that takes? Have you
done one of those before? So typically
what happens is the permit holder finds
out that we have objected and requested
a hearing and then they will come to the
city and they will ask what our issues
are and why we are objecting and then we
try to work out some kind of plan where
we can address the city's issues. Um and
if they're not
seriously concerning, still allow the
permit holder to go ahead and get the
permit. Um sometimes it's it's um
additional reporting requirements,
um making sure that employees are
background checked and identifiable in
in case they're, you know, doing things
illegally. Um a variety of different
things. Um we can require them to
maintain their security camera footage
for an extended period of time because a
lot of them just run it in a constant
loop and erase it automatically within,
you know, hours. Um
There there's a variety of different
things you can do if you have concerns
about a location. Yes. Okay. Um So what
I'm hearing for the group is
if we make a motion to object, it goes
to hearing. It seems to give us a little
bit or the city a little bit more
question and answer. Not I don't want to
say control, but a little more question
and answer and we get some of our
questions answered
at this hearing or in Prior to in
process.
>> Prior to, yeah.
All right, more questions? It's more of
a question for the body as a whole, but
I'm just trying to think of, you know,
looking out for the city's, you know,
interest for public safety, but at the
same time also respecting the fact that
this is a new business and we're not
creating more hurdles for new businesses
in the city. Um would it probably be
more advantageous
once again asking the group as a whole
if maybe we call a special council
meeting, say next Monday for the
purposes of discussing this license.
Once again, I'm just trying to think of
balancing the interest, like I said, of
public safety, but also of a new
business coming to town. Just throwing
that out as a suggestion.
Other questions?
My issue is if we're going to object
or have, you know, I take an issue with
this, I think we'd have to
say what the issue is.
Something specific. And that's And
that's And we don't really know what is
the problem is. And that's not the we're
we're kind of objecting cuz we don't
have enough information. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> So That's essentially the objection. So
You're allowed to make that objection,
right? So they're supposed to give you
the background information. That's the
whole point and the police department
has indicated repeatedly to me that
they're not receiving these. Um you
know, like I said, when I reach out and
attempt to get them, I'm not getting
them either. So I don't know where
they're going or what's what's happening
with those, but that's that's enough of
a reason to object. The fact that you
don't have enough information to to say
one way or the other. And if you get the
information and you decide, you know,
that you are fine with whatever that
information shows, then you can withdraw
your objection. Right. Okay. So I will
accept a motion at this point.
Um motion to object. Second.
You're You're good with that?
So we roll call that? No, no. No, just a
voice vote. Voice vote's fine. Yep.
So we have a motion and a second to
object to the new permit issuance.
All those in favor signify signify by
saying aye.
Aye. Aye. Same sign.
Yeah, whatever I said. So everybody's
cool with objecting. Yeah. Is that what
I got?
All right. So motion to object.
Carried.
Yes, you can have it back. Sorry.
That's got me all thrown off now. Any
other new business?
We want to run through committee updates
real quick.
Yes, Mr. Sully.
Thank you.
Um
So we we just had our we had a a meeting
uh
our first meeting uh 2 weeks ago.
Uh week and a half ago roughly and uh
I'm scheduling a special meeting to
discuss the uh
additional zoning changes for this year.
Uh that date's not been set yet, but
it'll be within the next probably 10
calendar days.
Okay. That was for code enforcement and
zoning committee.
>> and zoning. Awesome. Thank you.
Mr. Bisjack. Thank you, Mr. President.
Uh not really much to share at this time
from the safety committee. All the
safety committee business has already
been introduced for a first reading
tonight. So that's that's pretty much
it, but I do want to share the next
safety committee meeting will be June
5th, 8:00 in the morning in the 1897
uh conference room. So look forward to
seeing everybody there. Thank you. All
right. Thank you. Ms. Colon.
Uh no report for administrative
services. Our next meeting is May 22nd
at 2:00 p.m.
uh in the conference room.
Okay, thank you. Mr. Ailes.
I just want to thank the guys from the
the tree commission for coming tonight
and I, you know,
I I go to tree commission meetings and
have for
3 years and I enjoy them. I've learned a
lot and we've got good people. They're
doing really good things and we should
support them as much as we possibly can.
That's That's my speech tonight. Thank
you. Ms. Smiley. I do agree with that
and I thought it was very important to
have NOPEC here and to understand how
that's impacting us and then the tree
commission right after and how that's
impacting us. So
beautifully laid out in my personal
opinion.
The law committee met last Friday
and I do have two pieces of legislation
that are going to be coming forward in
May. One of them to amend the flood
damage reduction
and that's going to address the base
flood plain and the AO area. So more
information on that and then we also
discussed amending the west side TIF
that the previous council had approved
and we do have an amendment to that in
this well. And then we did go over the
budget in for the first quarter. Um
happy to say on target and no concerns
with the balances in the funds available
and allocated appropriately. And our
next meeting is June 26th at 12:30.
Great. Thank you.
I'm going to skip my
finance update because we all sat
through it earlier. And I'll shoot it to
Mr. Aug.
Uh nothing to report at this time.
And that was for
Yeah, I don't have anything
>> safety as well. Thank you.
Uh Mr. Carr.
We had our last public works committee
meeting on Friday morning.
Um street improvement projects uh
proceed. We'll start work on the 6th
Avenue bridge.
Um and on Arbor Valley Drive in May.
Um We'll tease to the next meeting on a
very on a specific uh street project uh
that'll be discussed in more depth uh
next meeting and at a high level
we had uh some conversation on uh a
pending reorganization of uh public
works
with uh superintendent Tim Deitz's
retirement. I'll kind of pass that to
Mayor McDaniel for high level
conversation on that.
Sure. We at public works uh committee,
myself and director Woody introduced uh
our plans to um
a little background. As you know, last
year, or actually about 2 years ago,
uh we combined GIS and IT, uh
consolidated that operation under one IT
department. And then the same year, uh
we merged building, planning, zoning,
and community development into one
department. All those things were done
for efficiency and for cost savings and
for streamlining operations for the
community.
For for instance, building, planning,
zoning now, you come to one window,
you get answers for all those questions
at one one place, a one-stop shop.
I believe it's much more efficient. So,
when we talked
in the public works committee meeting
about uh creating a department of public
works, uh an an overview of what we're
talking about is the city the L dot and
engineering combining under one roof.
With the Well, not under one roof, but
under one department. They might be in
under different roofs, but they'll be in
one department. A department of public
works. What that does is it puts
the city's old electrical department,
which was combined with L dot 20 year 20
plus years ago, cemeteries, which is
part of L dot,
combined about 20 years ago,
L dot and engineering all under the
department of public works.
And the purpose truly is efficiency. Uh
quite often
the same projects are originating from
one or the other. The funding is crossed
over. Um
a lot of the responsibilities are are
crossing over and discussions and um
planning and then completing the job.
>> [cough]
>> They're all working together already.
Uh
this you know, we talked to the
department heads and and the leadership
in each department. And it just makes
sense. And why would we do it now?
Attrition. We have a superintendent
retiring
and we just had a uh engineer resign.
So, we have opportunities to look at the
operation, look at streamlining the
operation, look at how we can be more
effective, uh and get things done in a
more efficient way.
Uh there'll be more details to follow,
but that's kind of a broad overview. Um
The city engineer's here. I don't know
if you want to add anything, Kurt.
Uh I'll just I'll just add um my
support [clears throat] for this.
Um We've worked with L dot since I've
been here for 10 years
on a weekly basis on what streets are we
going to pave and and our inspections
and and it really does make a lot of
sense for us to um combine into one
department. And what I'd like to see,
and we got to work out all the details,
is to
fill in maybe some lower level
positions,
um
you know, streamline at the top and and
get more guys in the field. There's
plenty of work to be done.
And we're hoping we can fill in some
lower level positions, um
give those folks an opportunity to
um
the the next level. You know, we get a
lot of departments, there's a lot of
ceilings. And when you get one
department, you give everybody a chance
to uh progress and they're give them a
better career path and maybe get a
little better retainage, keep folks
around longer. I think right now
um some of the folks that have retired
in the last 5 years have been here a
really long time. Um and
it's just the nature of the beast. So,
now we're trying to get our next level
up to that. And I I think it's a a great
idea. I'm I'm excited about it and a
little bit anxious, but excited.
Very good. Thank you. Any questions?
Mr. Hales. Mayor, you had mentioned
including the the people the tree
commission people, the people that work
uh
Are you going to include those in this
group or you going to leave them in the
parks department?
>> of that are are not ready to be
It is something I think we should think
about. Um you know, the our
superintendent of parks currently is our
city arborist. Our you know, what what's
his official title, Larry? He is the
arborist.
>> Okay.
>> Although he doesn't
Justin is the only real arborist.
>> Correct. The certified out in the field
getting things done. Yes, I agree.
>> But he's not the arborist according to
the city.
>> It's it's that is an idea I think should
be discussed, but that's not part of
this initial phase.
Any other questions?
As it relates to cutting things, I
forgot to mention the mowing contract
window of end of effect in the
cemeteries last week. The grass was
getting kind of high. So, that's that's
mowing's mowing has started.
>> Mowing has commenced. Perfect. I'm going
to throw out there if anyone cares of my
opinion, but I being part of public
works um
for 8 years and
you know,
Kurt [clears throat] Kurt's always
showed up to those meetings. It's like
engineering has its own part of the
agenda because they do so much work
in public works with that department.
So, I mean, I like the I like the idea.
It seems the it made sense to combine
building and
and community development and all that,
and this makes just as much sense from
from my perspective. So,
that's my two cents.
So, any
anything else with public works?
No.
Mr. Neisely.
Yeah, thank you, Mr. President. Um the
only updates I have for service
committee are that um tonight we
approved legislation to allow the
sanitation department to first of all
pay off the rental that they were
renting for the new for the garbage
truck and then also to purchase a new
one
>> [snorts]
>> um while the other one is still being
assessed um for repairs. And uh but the
other update I have is that I know at
last council meeting there was a
discussion about um some folks getting
utility bills with with very different
uh due dates than what they typically
get. So, I just wanted to address that
for a second. Um the utilities
collections office has has put out a
statement and I and I spoke with Molly
personally about this as well, but
essentially uh in their rules and
regulations, it says that the um there
has to be 15 15 days between the bill
and the due date. Um and so, what they
found was that there were some some
residents, some city utility customers
that had their bills due earlier than 15
days and some that were due later than
15 days. And so, in an effort to kind of
standardize the 15-day due date from the
bill date, um some people saw their due
dates fluctuate, you know, as as much as
five or six days, I heard um some people
say. Um
So, that's the situation there, but I
just also want to point out that um
there is a built-in grace period uh for
all utility customers that [snorts] um
they have until the next um the next
bill date in order to pay their bill
before they're penalized. So,
I just wanted to uh with a late fee. So,
I just wanted to throw that out there.
Um otherwise, that's all the updates I
have. Our next meeting will be May 14th
at 7:30 a.m. in the 1897 conference
room. Thank you. Very good. Thank you.
Mrs. Hoop.
Thank you, Mr. President. Um
I have economic development and we
finally have a meeting coming up not
this Thursday, but next Thursday, April
30th at 7:30 in the morning.
And I don't have any updates other than
if you come, you can hear DDA and Visit
Fairfield County and the chamber all
speak and give updates. So, it's
entertaining to hear everything that's
going on. Thank you.
>> That's a pretty good in the know meeting
>> Mhm. for sure.
All right. Uh Mr. Mayor, do you have
anything?
I have nothing else. Okay.
All right. We will move on to
announcement of scheduled meetings.
>> I have next regular sessions of council
is May 4th, 2026 at 6:30 p.m. in council
chambers.
And then May 18th on 2026 at 6:30 p.m.
in council chambers here.
Thank you. We have no special scheduled
meetings, uh regularly scheduled
committee meetings. I have economic
development meeting April 30th, 2026 at
7:30 a.m. in the 1897 conference room,
city hall. Service committee meeting 18
May blah
May 14th, 2026 at 7:30 a.m. in the 1897
conference room in city hall. And
administrative committee meeting May
22nd, 2026 at 2:00 p.m. in the 1897
conference room in city hall.
And thank you. Reading of bills. I have
one from MNMNC
O for publication of permanent
ordinances 5-26, 6-26, and 7-26 for
$92.44.
Mr. Bishop, thank you, Mr. President. I
move that we pay the bills. Second.
We have a motion and second to pay the
bills. All those in favor signify by
saying aye. Aye.
>> Aye.
Motion carries to pay the bills. We have
no need for executive session.
And I would appreciate a motion to
adjourn.
>> I move to adjourn, Mr. President.
Second. Motion and a second to adjourn.
All those in favor? Aye.
>> Aye. Aye.
We are adjourned. Thank you very much
for coming.